(lively music)
(crowd applauds)
- Oh my gosh.
You look great.
Congratulations.
- Oh my gosh, thank you.
- You have a baby boy right?
- Baby boy, yes.
- [Kelly] Was it exciting?
(crowd applauds)
That's exciting.
I was excited when I found out
because I had a little girl just like you.
And then I had a little boy,
and I was excited because I
got one of both, were you?
- I'm one of both, and I think I'm good.
- [Kelly] You're done?
- Shop is closed, yes.
One of each.
It's exciting.
It definitely was, you
know, just a different way,
I did surrogacy.
- [Kelly] Yeah, this second time, right?
- The second time, yes.
The first time I carried on my own.
The second time I did surrogacy.
And it's, I mean, it's amazing.
- I wish I had known about that,
I had horrible pregnancies.
I was like hospitalized, and so-
- Oh my gosh..
- Yeah, but I didn't
really even know about it
or know what it was like in
my circle, but it's brilliant.
- It's amazing.
I had reasons why I
couldn't carry my second.
- [Kelly] No, me too.
- Right.
- And it's such a blessing
that we have this.
My sister Kim had two
babies through surrogacy,
she had two that she carried on her own
and her last two are through surrogacy.
If it wasn't for Kimberly, I definitely
don't think I would've
been as comfortable.
- You wouldn't have been aware?
- I wouldn't have been aware,
I wouldn't have know as much.
I watched her go through her
journey, and I'm so grateful
for how open she's always been
about her journey because...
And not every journey is the same,
mine was very different from hers.
I think her journey was way more...
I think she was more, maybe not involved,
I don't know the term, but like,
it was just more comfortable for her.
For me I'm such a control freak.
- Oh yeah, you'd be like,
"What are they eating?
What are they drinking?
What are they putting in their body?"
- You're a stranger, I
just have to trust you?
And I love my surrogate, she was amazing,
but I'm still like, I need
you sitting next to me
all the time, I need to
know what you're doing,
what are you eating?
So it was-
- [Kelly] I think I would've
been a little like that too
had I known, yeah.
- And a control freak,
I take as a compliment,
So I'm not offended that
I'm a control freak.
- I don't know if it's like a control...
Because people always say control freak,
but it's like, or you just
know what you want in life.
- You're very particular.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I think that that's fine.
- It's not fine for other people,
but it's great for me.
- It cuts through the BS.
Yeah, I think they need
to just get over it.
So wait, so you haven't
revealed your son's name yet,
so is it like a family name, like a hint?
- Well, my daughter
says his name is Snowy.
- [Kelly] Oh, your daughter?
- It's not Snowy, so that's the hint.
- I was like, were you a
big Game of Thrones fan?
- Oh my god.
- Jon Snow.
- I swear she just does things
to sort of like mess with me.
But his name is not Snowy
- Wait, was she excited,
because my daughter was...
I don't know how far apart yours are,
mine are like 22 months apart.
- She's four and he's three months.
- Oh, so she is like a little doll to him?
- [Khloé] Yes.
So I think she's at the age where...
And Kylie, my sister, just had a baby
and so I think it was like,
it's like cool for her,
like "Oh I have a baby too."
So I think that's the fun part for her.
But True is my girl,
so I think if it was just...
(audience coos)
- Oh my gosh.
- That's my little girl.
And it's her and I all the time,
so I think if, thank God Kylie had a baby,
because I think she
probably would've like,
suffocated him or something.
- It's so funny, it goes both ways,
no, it goes both ways.
They get very upset because they're like,
"No, she's mine," like to Mommy.
But like at the same time
she loves to play Mommy.
- Yeah.
- But True's going to school now.
So how's that adjustment been?
- She goes to school.
- It's weird because they're
in the house all the time
and then they're gone.
- School is really strange.
I mean, I thought, okay, you go to school
and it's like half a day.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- No, at this school they go a full day.
They're like real adults, I'm so sad.
It's probably harder on
me than it is on her.
But she knows how to work me.
So like the first two
weeks were really hard,
it was tears for both of us every day.
Like I just felt like a monster,
I'm leaving her there and she's crying,
like, I didn't know what to do,
so I would always be sitting
right outside the door
and waiting and the teacher's
like, "You need to leave.
You're making this worse."
(kelly laughs)
And I'm like, I'm one of those moms now.
But I know school's great,
I just think it's so weird,
I'm used to having her
with me all the time.
And also the whole like, I thought, oh,
you get like a break in the
day when your kid's at school.
No, you're going to school,
you make the lunches, do the
snacks, you go to carpool,
I'm lingering at the
school for like two hours
because I'm like making sure she's good.
By the time I get home you have
like, what, a couple hours,
like one or two hours, and you
have to go all the way back
and do the whole thing again.
I'm like, this is forever?
- I think maybe you're like
a better mom or something,
because my daughter was like, "Deuces,"
I was like listening to
her, my daughter was like,
"Peace, I'm gonna be good,"
like she didn't even-
- That would've been so much easier.
- I mean, yes, but like, I
kind of was like, I guess,
okay, maybe this is our
way of our love language.
- No, I think that means
you raised a really independent girl.
- She's very independent
- And that's great.
I think I've babied
True, like, I did this,
I created this monster, but
I'm sick and I sort of love it.
- You know what though?
I think what's different
though, is parents,
your generation too, like
with your generation of kid,
it's like, y'all were in COVID too
for a couple years with your kids,
and everybody was locked down, right?
So that's a different thing.
She in those like developmental years,
she's like with you constantly,
I think that was different too.
- And I love it.
I'm sick.
(kelly laughs)
I'm like, yes, you need me
and you don't wanna leave me.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- I'm sick.
Like if she would've been like,
"Deuces," I would've sobbed
and gone to a therapist immediately.
(crowd laughs)
- And I did not.
(khloé laughs)
- You're like, "Bye."
- I was like, you know what,
you should get into dance,
you should get into chess.
I was like, all the afterschool programs.
- How long do you wanna be here for?
- Yeah, I'm like, well, and
also there's so many cool,
I don't know like what kind
of school you grew up in,
but the school I grew up in didn't have as
many opportunities as they have now.
And I'm just like, girl
you got all these things
you could be doing at this
school, that's so awesome.
- And I get so excited that she can.
They do baking and different
instrument stuff set.
Like it's so exciting what they have,
I didn't have all that either.
- [Kelly] I know.
- But it is cool
- It's cool to volunteer
too, just to see your kids
like with other little humans existing.
- [Khloé] I know, I'll never leave.
And you're like, all
right, I'm doing all right.
- [Khloé] I know.
- Or like, oh God, we
should all go to therapy.
So in that clip you are talking
about living next door to your mom.
So how is that?
Because I love my mom.
I'm just saying, I don't even know
if my mom would wanna live
like right next door to me.
- I told you, we're sick.
(crowd laughs)
Like, we're weirdly
co-dependent on each other.
- [Kelly] You're a unit, though.
- We're a tribe, and we always say that.
And my mom and I live literally next door,
like we removed the property line,
and our house is like one big house.
I mean we have our own homes.
- It's like a compound kind of thing.
- Yeah, it's like a compound.
And then my other siblings
live in the same gated area.
So we're all in the same gated area.
And my mom is typically really cool
and chill and she's great.
So she's not an annoying mom to live with.
- Yeah, like a hoverer?
- Yeah, she's not a
helicopter mom, and she's fun,
but there are moments that I'm,
like, a little creeped out.
Like, okay, like you're
definitely watching me.
(kelly laughs)
Like the other day she
called and she was like,
it must have been 6:30 in the morning,
And she's like, "Who
just left your house?"
And I said, "Oh my God,
Who? I have no idea."
I genuinely had no idea.
And she's like, "I saw
white Porsche leaving,
tell me who slept over."
I go, "No, it's 6:30."
I'm thinking like, who was in my driveway?
And we called security and they were like
"Oh that was your mom's"
It was someone from my mom's house.
But I was like, why are
you looking out the window
wondering what car is coming or going?
It's 6:30 in the morning,
how long have you been
perched there watching me?
(kelly laughs)
Like the whole thing, it's a little weird.
- Perched?
- So I don't know how often she does that.
And also that was her own
car, or someone for her house.
So, I don't know why she's watching.
- I love that it was
someone that works with her
- [Khloé] Yes.
that was at your house.
- That she didn't even know.
I was like, "I don't know."
But it did freak me out a little bit.
But then I got more freaked out,
I'm like, how often are you watching me?
- I love that, how open y'all are.
Even though that conversation though,
that's pretty cool.
Anyway, you recently had a melanoma scare.
I didn't know this, somebody said this.
So are you okay now?
- Well, hence the tape on my face.
I thought, maybe.
But what happened?
- So I am just predisposed
to skin cancer, I assume.
I had melanoma removed
from my back when I was 19.
- [Kelly] Oh wow.
- And the reason why I'm
wanting to talk about this,
well one it's on my face, and it's been,
I had an operation, I
wanna say, I don't know,
eight weeks ago, something
like that, and people just...
There were all these stories
and all these things,
and I just was like, you know
what, it's bringing awareness,
it's for a good cause
at the end of the day.
I really just wanna highlight people
making sure that they
do their regular checks.
I go every three months
because I am at higher
risk for skin cancer.
But as you just saw on the screen,
it was the smallest little bump,
and for months I thought it
was just like a cystic pimple,
I got it shot with cortisone.
No one thought anything of
it, but it wouldn't go down.
And so I got it checked
and someone was like,
let's just biopsy it.
We shaved it, it came
back, and they were saying,
there's no way you at your
age, I'm 38, I guess melanoma's
like really more for either
really young kids or older,
I'm not a doctor so I'm not
gonna talk too much about this
in case I'm screwing anything up.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But we had to do a second
biopsy and it came back
that it was a tumor and
they had to operate.
And so I was like, "A tumor?" In my head,
tumors are like, these big
things that are hanging,
like, you know, what
you see in the movies.
So it was never once, I
never thought it was a tumor.
And so I'm really grateful
that I was proactive.
And we did the surgery, we got it removed,
and now I'm just healing,
and I have a scar,
and that will figure out.
- Like, I think a lot of us
are making dermatologists
appointments right now.
Like, that's what I'm doing.
- But that's what I'm so grateful for,
because I have had a couple
people that because of me
they've gone to their dermatologists,
they have had things, biopsies.
I've had friends that have had things
precancerous that are now removed.
And, you know, knowledge is power,
and if you know something you
can do something about it.
- [Kelly] Oh, I wanna know
right off the bat, yeah.
- Yes, I'm that way too.
(audience applauds)
- Yeah, I'm always,
like, getting checked up
with everything like that.